[Musique]
tellement difficile il avait l'air
vraiment sympa
il est beau votre panier la part des
résidents quand même plutôt l'amour est
dans le pré nos paysans quand même faut
s'en occuper vivent seuls à la campagne
c'est pas drôle a plutôt macarons on a
d'ailleurs un très bon pâtissier dans ma
circonscription pascal café fait des
supers macarons plus tôt jean moulin
enfin les deux c'est tellement difficile
de choisir entre les deux les deux
[Musique]
j'adore l'estac
mais franchement une femme dire psg om
jean raby psg mais l'année prochaine on
va passer en d1 et on va les manger le
psg bienvenue chez les ch'tis la faune
andouillettes 5 à 2,3 plutôt friends
allez un c'est quand même beaucoup plus
instable twitter ça me fatigue un peu
toujours verre à moitié plein et
d'ailleurs il est toujours plaindre
plutôt christian jacob bien s'y
attendait président quand même plutôt
circonscription je suis très bien dans
la circo j'adore me balader rencontrer
des gens c'est toujours génial et un
plaisir pour moi un vrai tout le figaro
soyons sérieux
[Musique]
les deux faux d2 quoi
fologo plutôt coeur de 3 le bloqueur de
froid qu'on laisse sur les quais voilà
la plus tôt françois baroin à 500 mille
pour cent
[Musique]
fast food parce que ça fait trop
longtemps que je suis pas allé dans un
fast food mais la bonne gastronomie
c'est extraordinaire allez les deux
aussi bas les deux tous les jours les
deux un peu les talons je m'en vais mais
les baskets je cours je cours toujours
quelle idée
[Musique]
la disease tant pis quoi j le colis
devraient plutôt confit de canard
ouais et on se ressert parce qu'il y en
a ras-le-bol du confinement tôt castex
il est vraiment casse tête
salut à bientôt
vous